hi and welcome to another gamespot
unboxing this time
for the all digital xbox series s that's
the new
next-gen xbox much smaller than the xbox
series x which packs more of a tech
punch
but the xbox series s is not to be
sniffed at so let's take a look at
what's inside this thing
quick look at the box before we open it
pretty standard
fair look at some of the games on the
back again
just like the series x bit awkward that
halo infinite is on there given the
delay but
delays happen also cyberpunk got delayed
that happened
but let's take a look inside
so one thing i can immediately tell you
just from handling this box is how much
lighter the series
s is compared to the series x which
was certainly chunky
but let's take a look inside
package like it's christmas basically
gift wrapped with a little
uh bow i guess around the middle let's
take a look at the accessories
product and warranty guide the most
exciting part of any new console uh
hdmi cable so in the xbox series x
they give you an hdmi 2.1 cable ultra
high speed
this is hdmi uh just a regular i believe
like a 2.0
it's not 2.1 it just says hdmi high
speed on it which makes sense because
the series s
outputs in 1440p it can't go up to you
know 8k
like the series x can um so it makes no
sense really to give you
a 2.1 cable next up power cable
pretty standard um if you have an xbox
one with this power cable not the old
ones that had the brick
um this one should work your old one
sorry should work with your new xbox
if you get a series s or x next up the
brand new controller
comes with batteries i long for the day
when xbox controllers don't require
double-a batteries but
i guess some a little tradition we're
taking into the next generation
but
brand new controller so same as the one
you're getting with the series x except
obviously this one is
white a quick overview um
new changes to the d-pad kind of more of
a rotational d-pad which feels quite
nice
a dedicated share button this time so no
longer are you having to
go in and out of menus to try and take
screenshots and share them you have a
very
like clear way of doing that that's just
right there on your controller
view button options face buttons and
thumbsticks feel exactly the same the
biggest difference is you know
texturized
uh trigger buttons um and little
texturized
grips on here little plastic texturized
grips
so for my money the elite series 2 is
still my favorite controller
it has that weight behind it um this is
still a fantastic controller you know an
xbox controller you're never really
going to go wrong
um but it's not as i don't know beefy or
powerful as i feel the elite series 2 is
but i will reserve full judgment until
i've played games with this thing
time for the console itself
oh i need to stop ripping consoles as
i'm unboxing them
uh let's take this out
quickly before we put this box down you
have a quick start guide
that just quickly tells you how to put
batteries in your controller how to sync
the controller to the console
as well as instructions to download the
xbox app on your smartphone
and that way you can very quickly just
get your console up and running
look at it it's tiny
i i said i was surprised when i saw the
series x in person because i thought the
series
x was going to be much bigger than it
was but i am genuinely surprised at the
size of the series s
now i understand how no one saw it in
the background of phil spencer's uh
office big phil's uh
okay
it's so small
i genuinely can't believe how small it
is it's like
god okay let's let's take a look at the
the console itself so on the front
you've got this nice
it's not a mcdonald's uh you know like
ordering
window it's you've got vents here you've
got a vent on the top of it
on this side too you've got some at the
back but let's let's explore it in
further detail so
front of the console it has it's quite
stock i mean obviously it doesn't have a
disk drive if we look at it from this
side
which is probably the the rotation this
is probably how you'll have it in your
house
uh doesn't have a disk drive so very
very important to note
if you are on the fence about getting a
series s or a series x so the series
x the black console comes with a disk
drive the series
s which is this small white one does not
meaning that you will have to download
and keep all your games
on the console itself don't buy disks
don't put disks on your christmas list
if you have this
because there's nowhere for it to go but
similarly to the series x
you've got a nice power button to press
there you're not going to accidentally
be turning this thing on and off
you've got a button to connect to your
controller
wirelessly and you've got a usb port at
the front
if you ever need to connect any
accessories to it if you're having it in
the vertical
uh position you've got like little
rubberized
feet it's very cute
and yeah you've got the same on the back
of it here if you want to have it flat
so looking at the ports on the back
you've got your ethernet
two more usbs to charge controllers
peripherals etc
you've got hdmi out you've got the
expansion card slot so
this is a 512 gigabyte solid state drive
um in terms of memory games these days
can get pretty big i think warzone right
now is
you know well over 100 gigabytes it's
probably closer to 200 at this point if
you have everything installed
so bear that in mind is that if you have
a series s and you're not in the
business
of downloading and deleting games after
you finish them if you want to keep a
bunch of games on your hard drive that
you're kind of hopping between
it's probably in your best interest to
get some kind of external storage so you
can get an official
card that will go in the slot that's
currently running at about 220 dollars
which is obviously a bit pricey but if
you go to
gamesboard.com michael heim has done a
very good
kind of explainer on using external hard
drives just standard usb ones
um and what the difference in load times
is like he was running those tests on a
series x but rest assured we'll also be
running them
for series s can't imagine there'll be
that much difference
in speeds but wait for michael to give
you the final word on that
and then finally at the bottom that's
where you plug in your ac power adapter
and in terms of weight uh it's
surprisingly light it's like the weight
of
maybe a hardback copy of the entire lord
of the rings
all three in one that's maybe
like it it's so surprisingly light and
small
i can't really believe it um
what a neat little guy
so there you have it that's everything
that comes in an xbox series
s retail box keep your eyes peeled to
gamespot.com and youtube.com
gamespot because we'll be putting this
little guy through his paces and
comparing him
to his big brother the xbox series x
thanks for watching
[Music]
you